technically Oh
the line
degree so Angela
[Music]
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are doing well
before I start I just want to remind you
guys that at the end of the video
there's going to be a charity link as
you know we are raising money for a
hospital ward in Gaza about a hundred
and forty six thousand pounds so please
do check that out before you do
inshallah closed video but welcome to
this video on this video we decided as
brothers to basically do a video
regarding fitness and bring the sunnah
of the prophet sallallaahu Selim in
today's in sha Allah and the reason why
I wanted to do this video is because
every time I come see the brothers and
we chill in their house and we were just
loose studying I was doing a lot of
stuff but we was mostly just lazy
sitting on the couch just not doing much
so I thought you know what why don't we
put our time I was spared timing to use
and keep a bit fit and obviously you
know back in the days I used to love
training a lot brother Orion trains
brother Moses tie training as well so I
just want let me put the interviews and
started training and you do have not
started no no no because I I used to
train back in the days I'm just saying
he's been training for awhile you just
died but marshal you know how long do
you do that's right okay so yeah okay
it's get emotional here okay but you can
see the bicep still still flex fix yeah
okay so yeah so I thought you know what
let's use this spare time and be active
in Charlotte so we start training so
today we're going to show you what I'm
going to show you basically how I train
each muscle group and brothers and
sisters and teach you guys how you can
use this brother Orion is going to touch
up on a few other stuff and how to eat
healthy etc etc brother Musa is going to
help us out with the work with a workout
in Sharla and we're gonna see how it
goes
and we're going to go straight into the
exercise but before we do brother I want
to just quickly touch up on something
Salaam alaikum
so basically we're going to start we're
going to show you guys
Ali's workout regime in a minute but
before we start the exercise I just want
to give you some tiny tips that's going
to help you throughout your workout for
the rest of your lives
the first most important thing when
you're working out whether you want to
lose weight or whether you want to gain
weight as in muscle whether any of that
whatever you want to do in terms of
workout the first and
foremost most important thing that you
need to focus on is your hydration you
need to be drinking as a male you need
to be drinking two liters of water every
single day on average and as a female
you need to be drinking at least one
point six liters of water every day
so basically water is the most important
thing whether you want to lose weight
for your fat to be burning for your for
your reactions and your body to occur to
occur you need water weather weather
that talks about and for what water
helps in everything for healthy skin etc
etc and even when you want to gain
muscle you need reactions in your body
to happen and that requires water and
another tip that you guys should follow
or try to follow is if you're trying to
lose weight when you're working out try
to wear like thick clothing who these
jumpers etc etc but if you wanna if you
want to build muscle and not lose weight
and not lose the fact that you have like
me you should try to work like try to
work out and let loose clothing like you
know not not so much layers not some
don't go don't go to the gym west when
it's 25 degrees wearing a hoodie wearing
a jumper wearing a jacket like you know
obviously cover Jomon tarted obviously
keep your modesty you know work out with
modesty and especially when you're at
home as well
you can do loads of workouts at home
when you're doing at home nobody around
is the main purpose that if you want to
do at home like you know if you don't
want to go out if you would a brother if
you would the sisters this is what we're
going to show you is the basic stuff
that you can use when you're at home and
use basic equipment to do it yeah and
also we all should know the hadith of
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi Salam
where he said the strong believer is
more beloved to Allah than the weak
believer and the scholars commented on
this and they said that the strength in
this hadith it refers to physical
strength so obviously during omuro time
we're told to uncover one of our
shoulders during the first few offs and
one of the reasons why we're told that
is because to show the strength of the
Muslims so that people can see the
Muslims and see look these guys are
strong but nowadays as Muslims all we
can see today is Muslims having their
bellies out the stomach showing because
we've lost the plot of being healthy and
that's why today we're going to focus on
showing the Muslims how to become
healthy and rod Ali's going to show us
show his workout
and is craziness so Bubba this is we're
gonna get straight into the exercise but
before we do obviously it's good to make
intention so we can get rewarded as
we're training and one of those
intentions that we should do is ask
Allah and say o Allah indeed we want to
train our body keep fit for your sake so
we can serve your Deen better and as
brother Adrian said you know a strong
believer is a better than a weak
believer in Iman and obviously in body
as well in body and strength so ensure
we're going to get straight into it make
like intentions and inshallah as we're
training we'll get rewards there off so
let's get straight into inshallah so
brothers and sisters we didn't want to
go into the exercise or showing you guys
are warming up etc which one is go
straight into it and obvious you can do
your own warming up in your own way
however you want to I'm just going to
show you guys how I train each muscle
group today obviously we're going to be
training biceps so I'm just going to
show you guys how I start my bicep
workout so I'll get the crowbar you know
you can wrap it how you want obviously
by Spencer you know just type it back
we'll square it so don't have it like
this or like that it's good timing right
in the middle so what I do is obviously
if you just go a little bit down yeah so
start from there right so how I work out
with this is brothers and sisters is you
can do this at home if you're if you're
a sister obvious if you're a female you
can use lighter weights if you're a
brother you know what your strength is
so work work on that inshallah so what I
usually do is I do eight reps I do four
sets of eight reps right if I find it
hard for example if I go on the if I'm
doing my six rep and it's really really
hard for me oh I'll do is I'll just take
a bit of weight off so inshallah I
couldn't do eight reps so obviously we
keep our back straight your back should
be straight inshallah because you don't
want to do if you know something with
this you just show the example with a
book you know yeah that yeah they start
doing this they using their back so we
don't want to do that we just want to
keep your back straight inshallah do
these do these close eight reps or four
sets in size this is how I start from a
bicep training so guys after we've done
our our work out on our curl bar
obviously between each interval if
you've done eight reps take a minute
break come back to your eight reps for
four sets so you do it four times
now after we've moved on from that we're
going to rest a bit
couple of minutes and move on to our
next workout which is the Hammers
inshaallah has more so have to say yes
so it must've fixed it up now with this
we don't want to do the same training
over again because you see when you must
will get used to a certain way of doing
exercise it doesn't become effective
because you're doing it with the curl
bar now you do the same exercise that
was a dumbbell so we're going to do it
differently where most of the crosses
over so as you can see it's better to do
one each you can choose to do them both
if you but what most is doing is much
more effective as you can see and you
when you're training promises like I
said don't move your back you know
because if the weights are too heavy
that means you're using your back so
inshallah do this and you don't want to
do it fast or too slow do you get I'm
trying to say so this is the perfect way
of doing it we do four sets of eight
reps again
so four times eight and you have a
minute rest is each in between each
exercise
alexxa Brava the sisters we're going to
do three sets of insha'allah between six
and eight reps on this concentration
curl which brother most is going to show
me inshaallah so what we do is obviously
if you have this at home it's good to
use this it's really good but if you
don't have any minute we're going to
show an alternative that you can use in
Charlotte so with these these
specifically target the bicep muscles
like you know and as you can see brother
moves up you know the way he's doing it
Marshall he's not putting it all the way
downwards on the straight just a little
bit code this will help you each other
tone the bicep muscle inshallah even
better so if you don't have this at home
there's another alternative which one
I'm also going to show you the shoulder
for them so what was the sisters if you
don't have that equipment in your house
you can use your need to do the same
movement any Charlotte will be as
effective but one way of not doing is if
you can see muscles right elbow it
shouldn't be over your fight it should
be just decided getting support for
which if you brother Muslim show just
like this so you do three sets of eight
reps so once you've done your a rep you
take a minute rest and then you do eight
again a minute rest and eight again once
you've done this we're going to go into
a final exercise in trouble so guys
after we've done our four sets another
four sets and our last three sets on the
bench with this our muscles our bicep
muscle arms are going to be really tired
so what we want to do is we want to use
a curb are again with very light weights
and what we're going to do is we're
going to do 20 ones which is if we're
going to show in shut up which is for
example you're going to do seven halfway
up after you've done seven feet and
seven half Steve done seven you do half
way down and after you've done that
seven you do full so you do seven seven
of these so this is one set done and you
repeat this which you can choose of two
sets or one set one three set it's up to
you and your bicep exercise is done
we're going to move on to shoulders
insha'Allah
okay so guys this is the shoulder
exercise now what brother always going
to do for us is going to be doing a
short exercises and we're going to do
four sets again with a trips usually I
tend to do for example four reps behind
the back of my head and three and four
in front so do for back and four in the
front you can do ahead of you I can do
one back one front or four back for a
front however you like to do it and this
will train your shoulder exercises and
once you've done this it's the same
routine again after eight reps you take
a minute rest eight reps a minute rest
eight reps a minute rest eight reps and
we finalize it and
okay with this exercise what brother are
always going to show us is we're going
to change the middle part of the
shoulders with bit exercise we're going
to do four sets of eight reps so how
we're going to do this I'm going to make
it a bit more clear for you guys what
I've done eight reps is our first set so
we're going to be changing the front
part of the shoulders on our second set
like this or you can choose to do that
it doesn't really matter that much so
once again I'm just going to repeat I
will first set we're going to be doing
this eight times once we've done that
when I was sick and set we're going to
be doing this eight times and then on
our third set we're going to go back to
doing this and on our last set we're
going to be doing this we're going to
finish off with that so basically we're
going to go on to our final shoulder
exercise of the day and brother Ali's
going to show one of his own personal
workouts that he made up and basically
what he's doing is he's first he's
working on his middle shoulders by
lifting up his shoulders and then when
he pushes it out he works on the front
shoulders shoulders so this work this is
like a compact between your middle
shoulder and your front shoulders and
brother Ali does three sets and he does
eight reps on each set and he first does
it clockwise and then he changes us to
anti-clockwise on every set so you guys
can change this up you can do more sets
more reps or you can do lower sets and
lower reps and now we're going to go
into sparring in Sharla okay so brothers
and sisters after we've done our two
shoulder exercise four sets of eight
reps four sets of eight reps and we
finished off with as you know the pilot
I showed you clockwise three sets of
that we're just going to do a bit of
sparring with the obviously with the
pads bar we don't have pads so we're
using a boxing gloves inshallah and this
will ensure a really work out the
shoulders to its point and finish off so
what we're going to do is it's very
basic if you're at home with the sisters
or the brothers you can do the same
thing just don't knock out each other
and don't punch each other face so it's
like
[Music]
and you can do many different exercise
that for example just keep punching yeah
uppercut side for the side for example
so so you have many exercise that you
can do until you are really tired
stop take a rest go again once it enough
is enough that's the show okay guys so
um on today's exercise we're going to
show you how to train your chest in sha
allah and we're hitting the chest on
this is important if you have a bench
high it works up in part of your chest
it is flat out all this is the it's the
middle and it is really declined it's
obviously the bottom of your chest
insha'Allah so you can do this however
you like obviously if you're a male
obviously you know your waist if you're
a female you can do it lighter weights
inshallah so the problem also goes down
oh brother moose is going to do post it
eight reps inshallah so you wanna have
the balls perfectly just just around
shoulder length you don't it too wide or
too close lips
bring it to your chest don't let it
settle on your chest it's like kind of
close and back off as you can see look
in your arms one you know if you want
more concentration of the chest don't
lock your office so doing a trips and
once you've done this four times four
sets of eight reps we're going to go
straight into our new exercise inshallah
alright so after you've done a bench
press or four sets of eight reps we're
going to do chest flies which brother is
going to show us you can do this either
with having it on straight or if you can
choose to you can have it just a little
bit curl and this will help work the
outside of your chest inshallah as you
bring your closer the inside as you can
see so you do four sets of eight reps
and as you guys know a minute rest each
time and like I said you know your own
weights in shuttle however you can do it
with this you don't need it doesn't need
to be really really heavy but after
you've done this we're going to go
straight on to our next exercise to hit
the chest muscles and even more hard
inshallah
but brother is going to show us how to
do it with the dumbbells so you start
off yeah as you can see we're going to
do process of a trips if you can see how
he's doing so but it's straight when
he's bringing it down puts it to the
sides so we do eight reps of this on our
second set before we start off instead
of like this sorry instead of like this
we're going to start off like this and
then we're going to bring it down is
going to show us is to our sides so once
it it second set the opposite way and
we're going to do when repeat the same
cycle again and that will be done for
our chest for now okay guys so once you
finish training your chest exercise
which one sit under all the sets
obviously as you know when you're
training chest
you usually tend to work out your
triceps as well so while we're doing our
chest it's put to work the triceps or
brahmam also gonna show us how to do the
first exercise obviously to make a
traffic controller so you can do three
sets with this one star for three sets
of eight reps as you can see you know
you can do it there or you can bring it
behind your head when you're laid down
as you can see you do eight reps of that
three times and once you've done that
we're going to go straight to our next
exercise so brother Owen is going to
show us our second exercise on how to
train our triceps honest us start off
with it on you so you do again three
sets or four sets if you like of eight
reps and then once you've done that you
turn to your other arm mashaallah
swapping with the other arm and do the
same exercise and this will work out
your triceps and Charlotte saw three
sets or four sets of eight reps don't
guys our third exercise is this and we
finished our tricep off inshallah as you
can see you can do three sets two sets
you like and with all the exercises that
we showed you you know if you want to
increase the reps you know if you want
to get toned if you want to get big
increase the weight lower the sets but
don't go lower than I'll say six and
shoulder and yeah that's about it in
Charlotte for triceps as well so
brothers and sisters as you saw we work
different parts of the body and now I
just want to highlight to you guys
obviously this is not something that's
really professional professional
but these exercise if you carry this on
inshallah it will ensure that with a
amount of time of five to six months you
will get your body into shape inshallah
and like I said you know your body best
you know what weights to lift inshallah
what your body can obviously has the
strength to lift and put that into
perspective as well when you're doing
these trainings and like I said when you
do your biceps that's one day let's say
you try to change your biceps on Monday
give your arms rest because you're going
to use your arms for the next following
days to do your chest exercise or your
shoulder exercise or whatever exercise
you want to really do so basically if
you train your biceps on a Monday give
your arms about two days to rest
so Monday you've done X these exercise
Tuesday Wednesday you rest Thursday for
example you do shoulders once you've
done your shoulders usually shoulders
kind of tend to get recovered a bit more
quicker you can wait a day or two days
and then you do your chest exercise with
your triceps then you start the whole
process again chest once you've done the
chest and tricep exercise rest for about
a day or two go back to the biceps now
one last thing that I want to tell you
guys is when I when you guys are
training obviously as you've seen it
will say exercise one exercise to
exercise three now what I would say is
do not do the same method let's say for
example you do the same method exercise
one two and three for each muscle group
and for four or five months what will
happen is your muscles will end up
getting used to this exercise and then
it would not have as much effect on the
muscles and you won't get toned so what
you can do is swap them around for
example exercise 3 do that first or
exercise 2 stuff with that first
exercise 1 mix and match them so once
you do this then your your body your
muscles will get a shock because you're
doing something that is not used to so
ensure that that's about above the
sisters like I said it's nothing really
professional but inshallah you guys have
benefit
also as you guys know when you're
training a lot of people in the gym
start shouting and doing noises it's
good to do a victory of Allah as well
you know inshaallah remembrance of allah
and your rewards will be inshallah even
greater so try to implement if there's
anything that we missed out you know
please forgive us inshaallah
and yeah that's about it for muscle hope
you guys have enjoyed it please keep fit
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah better
care too
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you